Life is suffering,
right?
Indisputable.
What do you do about that?
You,
you voluntarily accepted and then strive
to overcome the suffering.
That's a consequence of that and you do
that for you and you do that in a way
that makes it better for other people
and then that works and one question
might be,
well,
how well does it work?
And the answer is you're.
The only way that you can find out is by
trying it.
That's it.
That's the existential element of it.
The proof is to be derived by the
incarnation of the attitude in your own
life.
No one can tell you how it will work for
you.
It's the thing that your destiny is to
discover that and you have to make.
You have to make the decisions to begin
with.
It's like because you can't do this
without commitment,
you have to commit to it first.
That's the act of faith that the
character guard was so insistent upon.
You have to say,
I'm going to act as if being as good.
I'm going to act as if truth is the
pathway to enlightenment.
I'm going to act as if I should pursue
the deepest meaning possible in my life,
and there's there's reasons to do none
of those,
their real reasons,
so it's really a decision,
but you can't find out what the
consequences of the decision is unless
you make the decision.
I think the same thing happens when you
get married.
By the way,
if you think you might leave,
you're not married and then you think,
well,
the marriage didn't succeed.
It's like,
well,
maybe you were never married because the
rule is you don't get to leave and
there's a reason for that rule.
Now I'm not saying that there aren't
situations where there should be
exceptions made for that.
That's not the point.
The point is that there's some games you
don't get to play unless you're all in,
and the other thing that's so
interesting about being alive is that
you're all in.
No matter what you do,
This is going to kill you.
So I think you might as well play the
most magnificent game you can while
you're waiting,
because do you have anything better to
do?
Really?
Why not?
Pick the best thing possible that you
could do.
Why not do that?
Maybe you could justify you're wretched
existence to yourself that way I think
you could.
That's what it looks like.
You know,
people find such meaning in the
responsibilities they adopted,
stops making them ask questions about
what life is for.
If you have a newborn child,
for example,
like unless you're really in a bad way,
psychotically depressed or or maybe your
personality really needs some retooling,
you stop thinking about
anything but ensuring that that baby is
doing well and if someone comes along
and asks you an existential question
about your commitment to that,
the right response is why are you asking
me such stupid questions when,
when the,
when this,
this is manifesting itself right in
front of your eyes like how blind can
you be?
That isn't a time for,
for questions about the meaning of life.
The answer is right in front of you and
if you can't see it,
it's not because life has no meaning.
It's because you're blind mean.
That's what they image of the Virgin
mother and the child is all about.
It's like,
what's the answer to the meaning of
life?
Here's an answer.
It's like,
well,
I'm going to criticize that.
Well,
go right ahead.
You know?
It's like.
It's like what?
What?
You're.
You're like a,
you're like a,
what do you call that?
A termite.
Knowing on a temple,
there's no,
there's no utility and that sort of
criticism.
It's blindness and it's the same thing
with regards to the path of the hero.
It's like it glistens in front of you
and you can criticize it.
It's like,
fine.
Put the cart before the horse and see
how far you get.
So I thought to bring full closure to
the class,
I was trying to solve this terrible
puzzle that confronted me for and many
other people about how it was that human
beings got themselves in such a tangle
about what they believed,
such a tangle that we were pointing the
ultimate weapons of destruction at one
another.
Which by the way,
we are still doing.
I thought,
okay,
well I understand that we need their
belief systems.
They orient us and that means there will
be conflict between belief systems and
that can be a catastrophe and that's
being played out everywhere.
Again,
in very many ways.
What's the solution to that?
Well,
one possibility is there is no solution.
It's just mayhem all the way around
could be the case,
but it seemed to me as I delved into it
that the proper solution to that was to
live properly as an individual because
you're more powerful than you think way
more powerful than you think.
I mean God only knows what you are in
the final analysis.
You're blind to your own weaknesses,
but you're also blind to your own
strengths and so then I think,
well,
if you got your act together,
it'd be better for you and instantly it
would be better for your family.
Assuming they wanted you to get your act
together and not everyone does,
but.
And then it would be better for the
community.
It's like how far can you take that if
you stopped wasting time and if you
start lying and if you oriented yourself
to the highest possible good that you
could conceive of and you committed to
that,
how much good could you do?
Well,
I would say money.
Find out.
So that's what I think you should do.
You should find out you don't have
anything better to do and there was
nothing in it as far as I've been able
to tell.
There's nothing in it but good.
So
maybe you could sort yourself out so
that you wanted nothing but the good and
and then maybe you could help make that
manifest in the world and maybe we
wouldn't have all these terrible
problems.
Then at least we'd have fewer of them
and that would be a start.
So it's the,
it's the,
the answer to the problem of humanity is
the,
is the,
is the integrity of the individual.
That's the answer.
So and states that are predicated on
that realization are healthy.
So in states that aren't,
are doomed to stagnation and
catastrophic collapse and personalities
that are predicated on self tyranny.
And the tyranny of others are doomed and
doomed to collapse.
So and then you think,
well,
what's the barrier?
The barriers are you willing to accept
the responsibility and part of the
answer to that is reduced the damn
responsibility until it's tolerable.
You don't have to have to fix everything
at once.
You could just start by fixing the
things that you could fix or you could
even do it more.
You can do it with even less self
sacrifice.
You could start by fixing only the
things that you want to fix.
God,
you can get a massive way that way.
So do it.
See what happens.
That's what you should have been taught
in university right from the beginning.
It's like aim at the highest good tool
yourself into something that can attain
it and go out there and manifested in
the world and everything.
That everything that comes your way will
be
everything that comes your way will be a
blessing.
And so,
oh,
you have to do is give up your
resentment and your hatred.
I know that's a hard thing to give up
because he had plenty of reason for it.
That's probably a good place to stop
console.
It was a pleasure.